everyone a so I'm Nick and I'm an
open-source maintainer hi everyone I'm
Jeff I'm also an open-source maintainer
and collectively with jerks okay the
kidding aside this is a topic that we're
particularly passionate about
we are both open-source maintainer so
that gives us a little bit of
credibility in terms of starting this
conversation it's not an endpoint it's
not really you must go and do this we've
got some calls to actions at the end but
it's really about starting the
conversation for those who don't
contribute to open source software and
continuing that conversation for people
who already are contributing to open
source software so but let you do proper
intros now so my name's Nick Randolph I
run a consulting company called built to
roam we do cross-platform apps and
services in the cloud just like every
other consulting company out there and
well come on let's be real about this
and we can I contribute actively to a
project called M nvm cross and I guess
my history there is I saw this as
something that I wanted to get back I
project that's contributed so much to
the projects that I deliver for my
customers hi I'm Geoff Huntley I'm an
open source software engineer I'm a
maintainer of an open source project
called reactive UI it's very very
similar to MDM cross we interface quite
a lot with a lot of business software
developers and I happily got him I got
involved where open source development
five years ago for my personal
development and growth and we're not
just really good friends it's actually
because the camera site mate means that
we need to sit to the side otherwise
idea okay so the agenda for today is
we're going to spend a bit of time
looking at why people and companies
should contribute back to open source
and we'll talk about how they can
actually contribute and then we'll wrap
it up and talk a little bit more about
how much should get one contribute
because it's all very well to say yeah I
should contribute and you know once a
year you're going log a ticket
like that's not contributing right so
how much should you contribute back to
an open source project we're going to
start off with a bit of a breakdown as
to why individually we contribute so
I'll hand over to Jeff Thank You Nick
so five years ago I was working at an
enterprise company and I kind of hit the
upper limit of my personal growth I
looked around locally and I couldn't
find any mentors and it turns out
open-source is a fantastic
to get like five years of growth in like
a single year you start off just doing
the most mundane thing and all the
sudden there's no one else to fix that
thing so you got to learn that thing and
then you fix that thing and now you know
mentoring people how to fix that thing
and I really got involved open-source is
to just build my professional network
and I've succeeded in this in many ways
but I've also built a lot of friends at
its core open source is mates trading
mates trading favors with mates and
that's what open source is so fantastic
if you haven't got involved open source
I recommend that you do it's a fantastic
Avenue for open source traditionally if
you wanted to go build a bridge like in
a normal industry you need supply
materials planning and approval you
don't have this in software engineering
if you want to go build that that
software bridge you can you can go hang
out with the maintain as a sequel light
and learn from them exactly how to build
a database open source is a really good
opportunity for your personal
development and from a business
perspective the value proposition of
open source is very clear right I can go
out into any sort of package repository
and pull down things that you know all
hosts of people have been contributing
up but then the risk associated with it
comes to life because you know as a
company I'm going okay well I'm building
all of this stuff for my customers but
what am i basing it on though what's the
foundation of that and so you know
there's a whole host of reasons why
people say hey you should contribute to
open source software and these are all
quite dated now in the sense that
they've been around for a while and
people understand that you know I might
have a component that we built
internally that I release on open source
so that other people will use it and you
know that does a couple of things it you
know boost my PR for the company
basically says hey I'm contributing back
to the community it also means that
other people could outside the business
can actually contribute to it and I get
extra value out of it but the missing
thing out of all of these and I don't
expect you to read them is the fact that
underlying this is this thing called a
software supply chain right and you know
the check the chain of an open source
Protege contributing to the value to the
projects that I work for for a customer
if that supply chain disappears or
changes I
carrying a baby okay I have to I'm the
one who has to work out okay well how do
I service my customers going forward and
so I need to do a sort of a bit of a
retrospective and go okay well how do I
protect that sort of software supply
chain before we go on let's actually
stop and take a bit of a back step and
actually look at what open source
software actually is so open source
software in essence is mates trading
favors with mates
it's the hacker spirit but technically
the word open source is a trademark it
was an initiative created 20 years ago
and that's trademark has the rules of
usage on this framework mark and they
specifically list an open-source license
isn't open source unless it has the
following freedoms and these guidelines
were designed around a freedoms of
consumption and releasing the maintainer
zuv liability for their creations and
like in 2000 proprietary software was
the enemy that was 20 years ago now like
proprietress software's the enemy but
like now 20 years on like 2018 like open
source is one companies are using open
source software by default people choose
open source over proprietary software
and like maybe the narrative needs to
change now we maybe need to inspect this
did we get it right
what is it wrong like what is working
what is not working I think that's a
good point because I mean fundamentally
open source the way isn't it these days
is really mates trading favors with
mates it's a voluntary thing you know
one project might contribute to another
and vice versa so you know there is a
bit of this sort of trading of favors
and so that kind of goes okay well if
it's voluntary doesn't this lead to
problems yeah and like like because
we've defined open source in the terms
of freedom for consumers we haven't
really fought about like if that was
right we never really thought about the
cost of maintenance and supporting those
that you build upon and a good example
in the industry that's occurred is
heartbleed heartbleed is a classic
example of this problem happened a
couple of years ago and in essence what
we had was a couple open source open
source software developers an entire
industry the Tri software
build upon this SSL library and we had a
security issue in this library and it
caused billions of dollars worth of
damage and whilst they did have some
revenue for this project it turns out
that the companies were only paying them
to add new features no one was paying
him to resolve technical debt and this
is just a prime example of the problems
that happen if you don't support your
software supply chain this is billions
of dollars worth of damage to happen our
industry that could have been avoided
and and then the other side of this is
really oK we've talked about what
happens if there are actual issues with
the the deliverables of a project but
what happens if the project stop gets in
make getting maintained once if it goes
away completely I mean who's left
carrying the baby so to speak and and
that's a that's a problem that's hard to
quantify and actually very difficult to
find a solution to right so the key is
like open source is as is like it's in
the license we don't owe you anything
maintain as a software there what soon
as we release that software to the world
that's where our responsibilities end we
do not need to respond to github issues
there no need to create documentation
--zz don't need an answer document a
answer questions on stack overflow
releasing software is where the
obligation of maintainer and anything
past that point is they're going over
and above a level of service and people
that seem to have forgotten this it's
covered in the open source licenses the
software is as is but surely this means
that well maintain is a sort of like a
bit of like vendors really in the sense
that they're producing software that
other people are using
but again aren't we running into this
problem where you know there's this
expectation on maintainer x' to live up
to some form of S on you know
unreasonable SLA yeah let's say software
open source software maintain is our
vendors there are unpaid mend vendors
and they're held to an SLA when there is
no SLA and so industry why this is a
huge problem right this is a report by
cyanotype that looks at in this
particular case it's a Java and
JavaScript repositories but you can just
see the astronomical growth that there's
been over the last couple of years in
two
of the repository itself and so you know
this is a big problem and you know if we
don't address it as an industry then
it's gonna cause us ramifications going
forward this is actually a billion
dollar problem all right here's a quote
left on github last year and it was a
comment it was like I don't want a
target dotnet for I have to target
dotnet for my company runs a
billion-dollar business with commercial
software that is not compatible with
later versions of.net I have no power to
change this the lack of support for net
four is killing me and and this is
actually quite common you know if you've
ever maintained a project you'll get
people who raise issues and says what
about me I I have this particular
requirement I need it solved I don't
want it done now and if you don't
respond to it or leave it open or it
doesn't get any traction they'll come
back and they'll they'll post against it
and I'll post against it and virtually
every project I've seen maintains at
some point will jump in and address this
type of a thing right and like the
maintainer of this project replied with
like point me to one significant
contribution your billion-dollar company
has made to any open-source project in
the last month and I'll support dotnet
for now as a reminder dotnet for came
out in 2009 alright I kiss him at night
why are companies offloading their
company's problems onto unpaid
volunteers and like Simon like some crop
the maintainer apply had very similar
concerns like he's just researching his
rights like I guess the underlying
problem in this scenario is your problem
you have a problem your company refuses
to keep their software reasonably
up-to-date and your request for a free
open-source project in effect to keep
supporting you is to make your problem
someone else's problem and so how did so
I'm going to resolve this in the end
yeah so I'm Simon Simon closed off the
ticket actually even ticket it's closed
off the github issue ticket that's the
thing people use the word ticket that's
commercial terms yes it's a very trick
open-source is very tricky so Ibrahim to
your users yeah
so he be closed that office saying look
so again I'm sorry I'm gonna close this
I've updated the documentation I've
updated the minimum specified but let it
be clear Simon didn't need to do this by
even replying to that github issue he's
doing over and above what he was meant
to be doing like he could be spend time
with his friends he could be spending
time with his very patient and lovely
wife he's two dogs or watching Netflix
look the thing that I just don't get is
like previously companies would have
budget like for proprietary services and
that budget has evaporated and now
companies are getting services that
wouldn't they would normally pay for for
free and and the upshot here is that if
you look at the response back from Simon
he's very polite about it and he's gone
about it in a very diplomatic way and I
think he said look you know there are
various constraints on the project
constraints on the you know the
contributors and maintain us for their
time and their resources he's basically
saying look for the best for the best
interest of the project we can't
continue down this path and supporting
dotnet for now the thing is that doesn't
make him a jerk that just means that
he's focused on the Liberals of the
project right and I'd go so to Piratas
to say that nearly all maintain errs are
not jerks they just care more about the
project as a whole than any one
developer does and I think we are at a
point now where we need to start
resetting some expectations we need to
reset expectations for the people
consuming open source projects and we
need to reset expectations around a
level of contribution that those
consumers end up putting back into the
project you know there's a whole ton of
things we need to consider about you
know what happens if the project fails
well I'm is if a key maintained of you
know burns out I wouldn't say I've burnt
out but definitely if you look at my
contributions to github for the last six
or nine months it's been heavily on
every month up until September and
basically I got to a point in the
beginning of this month of every basic
you said all right I got to focus on
some other stuff right and so my green
bar has gone gray and it doesn't freak
me out and we'll get to that in a minute
but it's got to the point where I don't
feel that I'm in a position where I can
contribute on an ongoing basis to
interviewing across in you know
the next month or two and so that's
important thing because now all of a
sudden they need to look for other
people to support you WP and some of the
xamarin forum stuff that I was
previously taking on now by chance they
have actually got a couple of
contributors who are now jumping in and
fixing that stuff and addressing those
but it means that I can now take a bit
of a back step six sit-ins quite safely
knowing that it's in good hands yeah I
don't think there's anything
particularly wrong we've like open
source and the terms of it I just I
think that we just need to add like a
commons clause that actually talks about
specifically protecting the supply chain
and preventing situations of tragedy of
the Commons I think it's really
important to actually grow the
definition to water along the lines of
community and not and move the dialogue
past doing a commit like there is more
ways to contribute to open source than a
commit and definitely from the
perspective of a project we need to get
beyond okay an initial burst of activity
around you know delivering a version of
a project we actually not only need to
start thinking of the longevity or the
sustainability of a project and it's not
just - you know we've got three key
maintains we've got to get that to five
or ten or fifteen which you need to
think about what that means on an
ongoing basis and look there was a talk
given by Russell last year at PyCon au
and it was a fantastic talk I recommend
you go look at it it was beautiful and
he talks about software supply chains
and the main thing is like we've been
kind of mums the word as a software
industry about like money and open
source like it's actually kind of a
dirty topic and we have an established
the conditions where companies can
mitigate these risks how does how can a
company might mitigate these risks in
their supply chain how does a employee
go to a manager or to legal and have
these conversations it's been kind of
mums the word about all these type of
things and best practices haven't
haven't been developed and look
open-source needs to evolve to a vote to
consider the cost of maintenance and if
we evolve to the point of considering
the cost of maintenance we get to the
point where we looking at sustainability
and sustainability has a
a flow-on effect of diversity the people
who can get involved with open source
software traditionally men 18 to 25
years old and white anglo-saxon males
this is what open source is and in my
case I'm now 35 now have two kids I'm
having to dial down my involvement in
open source and that means the cycle
continues there's no mentor as a bar
blog to actually teach the younger
generations to not make the mistakes
that I did
it means that the perspective of open
source if we want to go if we got to the
point where have sustainability and open
source we can get to the point where we
could actually like if there's a work at
home mother they can do the github issue
triage like we could pay them like we
can change the face of open-source we've
got a level of sustainability and so
just coming back to looking at how we
then protect the supply chain I think
Jeff's alluded to it before there's this
sort of parallels between what we do in
software and what happens in other
industries like you know for example
building roads and bridges yes this lady
now do you Abigail
very interesting lady I highly suggest
that you follow her she published a
report two years ago called the roads
and bridges and this was done by the
Ford Foundation a commission for the
Ford Foundation out of a grant we're now
starting to see grants coming out grants
coming out and give them to people to
research complex problems to prevent
tragedy of the Commons situations and
she makes this brilliant analogy that
open source software is digital
infrastructure it's digital
infrastructure people just like drive on
by they consume it and it all works fine
the problem is in in the physical world
what we actually do have is well we've
got roads and bridges and we have
councils and councils pay someone to
maintain those roads who's paying the
maintained as a open source software
projects like everyone's just driving on
the highway so we're getting potholes
everywhere it's bad and so she's looking
into this collecting the data she
commissioned this report moved to github
did a bunch of data science they gather
more data on this subject and she's just
continuing on
if you want to get information for your
business go there and so as a business I
mean the question then comes out okay
what do I need to do to secure my supply
chain and so we need to think about you
know the level of contribution that my
business needs to make back into open
source and I guess the options that I
have for doing that and so I guess the
next part of this talk we are going to
focus on what a contribution is and how
much you should be contributing yeah so
the truth is free software really isn't
free like someone is paying the costs
like react
that's the subsidized project and what
happens when Facebook stops subsidizing
that project the project I maintain
reactive you I used to be subsidized by
github they no longer are using that
their technology in the community died
and that's where I came in I came in
doing community management and getting
involved in open source that was my
personal growth and development I loved
it but look if you can't help with money
help with time and a good example of
helping the time is there is initiative
called open source Friday open source
Friday calm and the idea is as a
engineering leader you reserve some time
in your sprint and if you have a
two-week sprint you reserve one day for
the personal development of your
employees and the idea here is those
employees during that 20% time they can
pull request an update they can pull
request and learn how that open source
software that they depend upon works and
it means you're having a positive
influence in the community you start
attracting people into your company and
showing that you contribute back to open
source you build a relationship we're
the open-source maintainer so if you hit
a critical issue in the next spread he's
more likely to willing to help you
because you've already helped him you're
doing the hacker spirit really really
important but I think I touched on the
need to commit by contribute via a
commit and it's like well there's a
whole bunch of areas even if you're
going to devote time and not money where
you can actually start to contribute
without necessarily doing pull requests
and commits right because you know if
some projects are harder to get into and
take more time to get your head
and all of the bells and whistles but
there's always a level that you can
contribute even if you've only got like
an hour here or an hour there and they
start with the sort of the you know the
dollars right at the top and then you
know if you look at some of the
management side of things you know who
manages the triage board who manages
what the features are the pit that the
developers are working on you know who
prioritizes Fixer who works out how to
reproduce issues or bugs you know
there's a there's a host of things out
there that um that don't you know result
in a commit or a pull request and yeah
just equally valuable to the the
livelihood of the open-source project I
think it's really important just don't
contribute just by code change your
dialogue and that even if you hear
someone saying I can't contribute
because I don't know the project that's
that's horse like they can contribute
it's really really really really simple
there's so many different ways you can
contribute blog posts writing blog post
shipping something on to github
helping out the community there's so
many different ways to contribute but
like really the only way only form a
contribution that's bad is no
contribution to coin a phrase this right
so just touching on this issue of
contribution being hard it is a
fundamental problem why why developers
often don't contribute back to our
projects they go okay well I don't know
the source code I would take you know be
too difficult to contribute and even if
they do know the source code actually
committing a you know change and getting
it through the pull request process can
quite often be a daunting task you know
quite often there's this sort of feeling
fear of failure that developers don't
want to go they don't want to put
something in the public that might be
criticized or might be you know might
have to undergo change before it's
committed but I think that one of the
things that like to point out is if you
find contributing hard then chances are
you're not alone
chances are there are other people
interested in contributing to that
project who stuck because they don't
know how wet or why to contribute so
placing foundations for the next person
behind you work out how you can make it
easy for the next person to contribute
to that project and then over time it'll
get easier and easier for people to
contribute contributing on developer
accessibility is like a fantastic thing
like it just pays off
I the maintainer czar continually
worried about how I get people into the
project and a lot of people don't
communicate their stress and frustration
when they're trying to contribute to a
project so if you really want to help
out a project and a maintainer there's a
couple things like actually signify that
you want to help out
just ask I would like to help you out
and then then focus on like sharing your
experiences in your pain in contribution
and resolve that and by doing that you
build up your relationship and over time
the code can wait I build your
relationship up focus on developer
accessibility and the code can wait
you can contribute before you read the
code and so Jeff I mean for reactive UI
I mean what are what are some of the
things that you guys have been working
on to make it easier for people yeah so
reactive UI one of things we have done
is we actually in github have issued
tags specifically talking about
developer experience contributor
experience and that's just basically
signalling that we care about these
things and we label certain things in a
particular way and we've had people just
randomly drop on by so I tried to clone
this on Visual Studio for Mac and it
didn't work and we go thank you very
much for letting us know and he goes
look I don't even use this software I
just saw that you care about this this
issue and here you go here's my feedback
we've been incorporating this feedback
we've been looking at because we support
so many so many platforms it's very hard
for everyone to have a domain knowledge
of like all the mobile platforms
televisions watches and stuff like that
so we divided it up into small little
section areas there's a convention of
github could code owners and code owners
allow you to go a far match anything in
the Android directory goes the Android
review team and a Nick you've been doing
quite a lot we've continuous delivery
yeah look we have and I think we're a
little bit further behind on both the CI
and also code owners and say reactive UI
but but I think one of the areas outside
of that and again it's an area where
people can engage quite heavily is we
actually have a thing called the
playground and so when you go to the
source code for everything across
there's a single solution file that
works in visual studio sometimes you
open it and there is this playground
there and
playground has a buildable runnable
version of an app for each platform that
we support and we as the is the
community so contributors and maintain
iners make sure that with each commit
and with each pull request those you
know playgrounds work and the reason
being is that if somebody goes to the
and raises an issue around an MDM cross
the first thing that we will respond
with is hey did you know that there's a
playgrounds you know in the source code
that you can actually go and run up and
would you mind going and see if you can
reproduce it there because we know that
project works you know we use it for all
of our development we know that it end
in pretty much works and quite often the
person who raised the issue will go ok
yeah yeah cool no worries
and then they'll get to the point where
they go ok well I've done that I can
reproduce it there and now what and we
just turned them and say well just issue
a pull request you know it's a work in
progress pull request and sure enough
they do it it appears in the list and
there's no fear of failure because it's
already broken
we know it's broken it says it in the
description of the pull request it's
broken right and so this this whole fear
of failure has completely gone away
right and so then we work progressively
with them either on the the pull request
itself or if there's an associated issue
we'll have common threads going they're
all quite often will actually just reach
out on slack or some other forum to
actually engage them to try and resolve
it quickly and get it out out of the
pile this but this notion of fear of
failure is something I Dre I encountered
when I started work on it I was going oh
I don't know whether I should commit
this or not and the reality is there's
no bad commit right this commits that
get accepted into the project this can
commits the don't write even if your PR
is a load of junk and actually doesn't
do what it's supposed to
there might be one commit that a
maintainer goes yeah I like what you've
done there there might be some code
formatting or something like that
yunk I'll you know pull that into my
next pull request and all of a sudden
we've improved the the workflow of the
project as a whole and it's also
important to remember like open source
intense is a hobby for a lot of people
so the bar is actually like a little bit
quieter would be a little bit lower and
it's just really really important to
actually it's really really important to
actually just send it in all
you and have a look at that work yeah
yeah we've got we've got an issue going
around at the moment to do with a change
to do with you WP support and it's
bounced around all you know quite a lot
because we all have differing opinions
to how it should it be implemented and
you know it'll probably bounce around
for another week before we get
consolidation on it and no one is
blaming nobody's pointing fingers at
each other because we're all trying to
get to a common goal we're all trying to
improve that the basis of the project so
it's really important to have that level
of engagement I would make one point
here is that there are some there's some
sort of open source documentation out
there that basically says everything
needs to be done in the in the open
which I I do agree I mean all decisions
should be reflected in you know poor
requests or issues that can be tracked
but the reality is the most productive
work you'll get done is on a slack
channel with somebody going hey I think
this this might work you know what do
you think about this that because you've
got that immediacy about it and that's
the thing that's that stumbles most
people on in terms of issues and pull
requests is you know there's a five hour
lag between you know when I code
something and when Europe wakes up and
and goes no that's a load of bollocks
right I don't want that no I wanted to
have done this way right whereas you
know if I know that you know one of the
maintainer is going to be online at the
end of my day I'll you know pop open
slack and go hey what do you think about
this you know is it worth me doing a
proof of concept around this you guys
yeah not and I'll go okay well maybe
I'll change my idea before I start
pushing it out there or I just literally
push it out there and know that he's
gonna reject it but it's all good right
all right so we want to touch on the
fact that no contribution is equal now
this isn't a reflection of whether
they're good bad or indifferent it's
just that the value to the project of
different contributions makes a
difference right and so if you're going
raising a lot of issues there's only a
small value to the project it highlights
problems it might in you know reflect a
level of interest in certain features
but the most value really comes out of
getting commits and pull request and I'm
isolating the conversation here to just
contributions by code right there are
other things that we've talked about in
terms of marketing and design and you
know those types of things that sit
outside the code so this is tailored
towards contributions by code the most
valuable ones there are the
the pull request that gets accepted
moving the project forward right now we
talked about the the green graph before
that freaks me out
so I'm the green graph okay so github
has two visualizations it has this graph
that shows activity on it on on a
day-by-day basis and there's this notion
of chasing the green don't chase the
green try and try and get a perfect
commits streak of like green for out the
year it doesn't end well don't do it but
they introduced this new visualization
recently which is like brilliant it's on
point it actually gives a bit of a shape
and it gives a visualization of like
your shape of contribution now it's not
perfect because it still has this notion
that a contribution is a commit there
are a lot of things you can do to help
an open-source project
that are not commit related so design
work right if you spend a couple of
months working on new design for open
source project and then you commit the
assets that's a single contribution what
so there's a couple problems with these
visualization this locking a
contribution to a commit but it's really
interesting here is like if you find
yourself like all the way on the right
just opening issues well start thinking
about how you can change that and like
set a goal and see if you're moving
across to and you can see getting more
involved approach you can see your shape
move more across to the left and if
you're an open-source maintainer like
look at the shape of someone and go oh
this person does a lot of code reviews
but they don't do code reviews in my
project why is that look at it and go
well hmm maybe there's a problem for
about high barrier contribution maybe
they need to install a large amount of
SDKs to get running start that
conversation use it to start a dialogue
it is beautiful the main thing here is
if you want to help out just use the
words how can I help you like how can I
help you it's the most magical words and
open source so the final section we're
going to talk about how much to
contribute there's often a challenge
that both individuals and companies face
right from an individual perspective hey
I'd love to go and spend hours just
hacking away right but you know I've got
other things like work and family life
and whatever to think about and so it
becomes a balance between where
I spend my time and similarly from a
corporate perspective you know you're
not going to spend you know 50 80
percent of your time contributing to an
open-source project but you might spend
10 or 20% of your developer resources
contributing but how do you define what
that balance point is and more
importantly which projects you're going
to contribute to so I've talked about
envy of course because I obviously feel
that that's got strategic benefit to
Bill to Rome but what else should I be
contributing to and and you know is
there some general patterns here we can
adopt and that she gives us some some
guidelines to follow in terms of working
out where we should should contribute
yeah
there's different levels of contribution
we touched on quickly about money and
not many people know this but we're
starting to get to this level of
crowdfunding and open source so there's
patreon and patreon funds the creators
but there's now also open collective
open collective funds projects and
that's a very important distinction
because we've open collective the
revenue goes to a 501 c c 6 non-profit
and when that money lands in that it
doesn't belong to any one particular
person it belongs to that nonprofit and
if a maintainer needs to have get access
to that money they raise an invoice to
that nonprofit it goes through expense
claim and approval and it's really
important because it allows the
succession and that money is not in the
name of the maintainer so it's not from
a taxation point of view there are open
source projects running on patreon I
highly suggest you switch across because
you get a taxation event for yourself
and then you pay someone else they also
get a taxation event it's not the most
efficient system so a good example of
this for money is I was down in
Australia Post and I spent $200 on
shipping our shipping stickers like for
the reactive UI project this is
grassroots marketing I purchased
stickers from the from as an expense and
errand know my wife she like like go
what you spent $200 you already give so
much to open-source in this project it's
like no don't worry about it I'm just
going to expense it and that
being able to do that is such a powerful
dialog like and this is the light that
some of the things that are just
absolutely changing and this comes back
to some of the softer errors of a
project we talked about it is that you
know quite often us geeks are all a lot
to just get in there a write code but
when you come to actually promoting a
project actually getting more people in
on it you need to start thinking about
marketing you need to think about
stickers and all of those types of
things that are gonna you know get
people's geek on but those don't come
for free and unless you've got somebody
with those skills actually already
contributing to the project you can't go
to a design house and say hey I run an
open-source project how about you donate
some of your time they'll look at you're
going what value does he give me I mean
because it's mates trading favors with
mates were always that where's the favor
in return right and so having this
financial backing does mean that you
know if you need to get design work done
so you look at both in view and cross
and reactive UI we have nice-ish logos
right I don't know where they actually
came from but you know if we had to come
up with a new logo or branding we could
actually now pay for those because we
have some of this funding so yeah
because like I drew spec work doesn't
mean everyone else should do spec work
that's not sustainable so if we want to
fix this terrific set the core and on
the money aspect there's a project
webpack small little project you may not
know that $400,000 us a year reoccurring
revenue there is some serious changes
happening in our industry reactive UI is
fortunate enough through companies
sponsoring and also through our users
we're at $10,000 a year reoccurring
revenue and we're starting to look at
this now that you had money what do you
do of it right and the answer to that is
we're going to use it to buy services we
can't attract open source projects so I
mean from a business perspective I mean
someone says oh you should financially
contribute to this project and I'm
thinking oh god there's gonna be like
thousands of dollars that I need to
contribute it doesn't right it can be
whatever you feel is necessary or feels
give you value right so it could be a
hundred bucks a year the important thing
is that's quite a nominal value to to
any business right and if you struggle
with that you've got other problems but
you know ten dollars to a project if you
multiply that by the number of people
who are using it and contributing to a
project that's so that's a reasonable
chunk of money for a project a year
yeah it is we're starting to look at we
once we get to this level of again doing
a website redesign getting tech writers
well maybe we can have like like a
dotnet conference for reactive UI I know
nvm cross had one recently as well yeah
I'm stepping away from the of the
financial side of things the the
progression from you know on
contributions of all goes roughly use a
contributor maintainer and this is
somewhat imposed by sort of things like
github which basically have different
sort of permission levels based on
whether you're like just a contributor
or whether you'd be nominated and
maintainer but from from a different
note they also reflect a level of
influence on the project and so what I
mean by that is if you look at users
they're just contributing issues right
once you start to step into a
contributor then all of a sudden you're
contributing fixes and features and you
got a little bit more control here right
you're so you're fixing problems that
are there and you're contributing new
features potentially but yeah at this
point you're not really dictating the
direction or influencing heavily the
direction of the project as a maintainer
and typically there's a very small
subset of contributors that end up being
maintained errs and that's for a bunch
of reasons it's not not through you know
lack of trying to get more people
engaged it's typically because there are
only a finite number of people who are
willing to contribute that level that
they really sway the direction of a
particular project and so that's where
we really see that this level of
influence very varies between different
contribution levels and so from a
company perspective looking at how I
protect my supply chain it's a matter of
how much influence do I need to have and
it doesn't need to be actively I don't
need to sway you know say in v1 costs to
go and do a particular thing because my
customer needs it but actually if you
start talking to some of the maintainer
--zz they'll go okay the reason that
this particular feature got done was
because my customer needed it and so
there is some self-interest there and it
comes down to the level of influence you
have on a project it's not that they
will put the direction of the project to
one side and go hey I need to go on this
wild tangent to do my thing normally
it's a matter of prioritization of bugs
and a bug might come up that's a really
high priority to a particular customer
that they're facing
so they'll
prioritize that maybe over and above
other things and remember this is all
about mates contributing favors to mates
right and it happens in the corporate
world as well and in the end of the day
you know the direction of the project is
going to be dictated by the maintainer
--zz they have their own agendas and
that's why it's important that they have
a community of them which you know
controls the direction of the project so
I guess this is sort of our end game for
this is and sort of came out at the very
last minute that we sort of realized
that there's this sort of contribute
contribution decision tree right and the
interesting thing is that we haven't
really talked about the first part it's
like can you actually influence a
particular project and so if you look at
something like dotnet okay some of it's
now open source as you as an individual
or as a company how much influence do
you really have overdone it sure you can
go and raise issues you can even try and
contribute some code but are you really
going to sway to the overall direction
of it through one issue or even a half a
dozen issues right you're not really
right so as a company am I going to sit
there and go okay well I'm going to put
a lot of cycles into it you know trying
to sway the direction of dotnet you know
I'm not sure they're going to go back to
done it for so that company's not
happening okay so you need to make that
decision first and you know the reality
is if you're not a you're not going to
influence it you might as well just be a
user of it right you could end up being
a backer if you feel that it you know
there's a lot of people doing good
they're not getting backing from some
other corporation you could definitely
be a backer but the reality is if you're
not able to really influence the project
you might as well just consume it the
next one is do you have capacity to
contribute and again that could be
financial it could be in time and so the
thing is there if you don't really have
capacity to contribute time you really
end up being a backer I mean and you
know if you're making use of say if I
was making you some mmm costs I didn't
have any capacity to contribute to it I
have a moral obligation to start funding
it in some way shape or form
indefinitely now that they as Jeff
mentioned there's this this pattern that
we can now follow for funding a project
without giving it to a particular
maintainer and say hey go and do what
you like with it
we now have a better mechanism for doing
that and this is maturity in the
industry right this didn't happen like
two or five years ago this really wasn't
there particular in the.net space where
is it currently it now is going beyond
whether we can contribute the question
is is it of strategic importance right
so I mean we use a bunch of you know
open source components you know we use
JSON down there we use it B of course we
use all sorts of things and whilst they
are all have some values of the project
there is a reality that a lot of them
can be chopped and changed with other
projects you know we made a decision to
use this particular json library now we
might change and switch over to another
one the reality is we're not going to
switch our MVM cross right we could and
we have done on certain other projects
we've used prism but the reality is we
have a lot of time and cycle was
invested in knowing and understanding
how many VM cross works so it wouldn't
make sense for us to heavily jump into
using prism on every project right and
so it does have a strategic value to us
which is why we choose to contribute to
it and the upshot from there is if it's
really strategic important to you you
shouldn't be a maintainer okay that's
the kind of level you should start to
contribute if a VM cross goes off on a
wild tangent it's gonna affect my
business right and so we I did make the
decision on behalf of my business today
to basically be a maintainer on that
project you know and that's not
devaluing what you can what you can
impact you can have as a contributor
it's not to say that their opinions are
less port important it's just a matter
of if you're contributing over time
you'll be able to influence it by bug
fixes and features and stuff like that
that you're working on all the time like
in your example here like net standard
came along with Windows and it's net
Center - Oh assumes you're running a
very very new version of latest version
of Windows if you need to target an
older version of Windows you need to
support net standard one and as an
open-source maintainer I really don't
want to do that I can if you come along
and say look I have the expertise in
this domain I will do that support
burden for you so you don't have to
there's no technical reason why we can't
like supporting it nets to net standard
down to one one
for react UI and other areas it's just
all comes with a cost and you have to
draw the line somewhere
so someone steps up and says look I'll
look after that for you so you don't
have to worry about it it's that's it
so Nick thank you very much for doing
what you did so I guess the the at the
end there are a couple of call to action
firstly this site this session has been
around protecting your software supply
chain so from a business perspective you
should start to think about okay well
what components am I making use of and
how do I make sure that those components
are going to exist going forward but
beyond that I think that we we need to
start thinking about sustainability of
projects we don't we shouldn't be just
spinning up any you know willy-nilly
project and then just letting it die in
wither
okay we need to think about you know is
this good for the good of community and
if it is you know how do we make it
sustainable how do we make sure that I
maintain is don't burn out how do we
make sure that you know we have a
natural attrition of people coming into
the project using it moving on and and
you know to make sure these projects are
here and you know for the if they need
to be going forward and so we do feel
that this is the start of a conversation
or maybe even we're in the middle of
this conversation but it's something
that does need to get a bit more
prominence out there and companies
really need to start thinking about what
they're contributing back to these
projects yeah we really need people
sharing their experiences and their the
best practices having a conversation
where client in mind who's up from
Melbourne and they had to sit here to
sit down through multiple layers of
engineering management HR and legal to
get approval to change employment
contracts to I'll even allow his
software developers to contribute
open-source this is what we're talking
about we actually first have to enable
the enable your engineers to contribute
open-source once you've done that you
start need to start categorizing what
open source you consume but you don't
categorize it from the basis of risk to
figure out where your risks are it's so
you've actually got data so you can
actually start going well actually this
software we critically dependent on it
if something was to happen if happened
to this software we would no longer be
delivering value to our customers
instead of delivering value to our
customers and they're paying for us
to deliver features we'd be working on a
JSON parser that's not delivering that's
not like what our customers pay us for
so start sharing or sharing your
experiences and your best practices and
it's really a point I made the point
about you know the financial
contribution doesn't have to be huge
huge but I do remember somebody quote
somewhere that this person was saying oh
it's too complex for my large
corporation to contribute such a small
amount I mean the overhead of the
paperwork would negate any contribution
this is like you fundamentally missed
the point ok yeah that's a problem go
and spend 4 hours on a Friday afternoon
and contribute some values of the
project I mean that's what it's really
about right it's not about you you know
your $10 coffee money that you're gonna
contribute I mean seriously
in closing look thank you all for
attending hopefully yours enthusiastic
about this topic as we are feel free to
connect to us with this outside of here
we're gonna hang around for quite a bit
so feel free to come up and you know
share your thoughts it is an ongoing
conversation and I'd love you guys all
to participate with it so thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]